last week i put up this video about
solving the game wordle or at least
trying to solve it using information
theory and i wanted to add a quick uh
what should we call this an addendum a
confession basically i just want to
explain a place where i made a mistake
it turns out there was a very slight bug
in the code that i was running to
recreate wordle and then run all of the
algorithms to solve it and test their
performance and it's one of those bugs
that affects a very small percentage of
cases so it was easy to miss and it has
only a very slight effect that for the
most part doesn't really matter
basically it had to do with how you
assign a color to a guess that has
multiple different letters in it for
example if you guess speed and the true
answer is abide how should you color
those two e's from the guess
well the way that it works with the
wordle conventions is that the first e
would be colored yellow and the second
one would be colored gray you might
think of that first one as matching up
with something from the true answer and
the grayness is telling you there is no
second e
by contrast if the answer was something
like erase both of those e's would be
colored yellow telling you that there is
a first e in a different location and
there's a second e also in a different
location similarly if one of the e's
hits and it's green then that second one
would be gray in the case where the true
answer has no second e
but it would be yellow in the case where
there is a second e and it's just in a
different location long story short
somewhere along the way i accidentally
introduced behavior that differs from
these conventions slightly
and honestly it was really dumb
basically at some point in the middle of
the project i wanted to speed up some of
the computations and i was trying a
little trick for how it computed the
value for this pattern between any given
pair of words
and you know i just didn't really think
it through and it introduced this slight
change the ironic part is that in the
end the actual way to make things
fastest is to pre-compute all those
patterns so that everything is just a
lookup and so it wouldn't matter how
long it takes to do each one especially
if you're writing hard to read buggy
code to make it happen you know you live
and you learn
as far as how this affects the actual
video i mean very little of substance
really changes of course the main
lessons about what is information what
is entropy all that stays the same every
now and then if i'm showing on screen
some distribution associated with a
given word that distribution might
actually be a little bit off because
some of the buckets associated with
various patterns should include either
more or fewer true answers even then it
doesn't really come up because it was
very rare that i would be showing a word
that had multiple letters that also hit
this edge case
but one of the very few things of
substance that does change and that
arguably does matter a fair bit was the
final conclusion around how if we want
to find the optimal possible score for
the wordle answer list what opening
guess does such an algorithm use
in the video i said the best performance
that i could find came from opening with
the word crane which was true only in
the sense that the algorithms were
playing a very slightly different game
after fixing it and re-running it all
there is a different answer for what the
theoretically optimal first guess is for
this particular list
and look i know that you know that the
point of the video is not to find some
technically optimal answer to some
random online game the point of the
video is to shamelessly hop on the
bandwagon of an internet trend to sneak
attack people with an information theory
lesson and that's all good i stand by
that part but i know how the internet
works and for a lot of people the one
main takeaway was what is the best
opener for the game wordle
and i get it i walked into that because
i put it in the thumbnail but presumably
you can forgive me if i want to add a
little correction here and a more
meaningful reason to circle back to all
this actually is that i never really
talked about what went into that final
analysis and it's interesting as a sub
lesson in its own right so that's worth
doing here
now if you'll recall most of our time
last video was spent on the challenge of
trying to write an algorithm to solve
wordle that did not use the official
list of all possible answers to my taste
that feels a bit like overfitting to a
test set and what's more fun is building
something that's resilient this is why
we went through the whole process of
looking at relative word frequencies in
the english language to come up with
some notion of how likely each one would
be to be included as a final answer
however for what we're doing here where
we're just trying to find an absolute
best performance period
i am incorporating that official list
and just shamelessly overfitting to the
test set which is to say we know with
certainty whether a word is included or
not and we can assign a uniform
probability to each one
if you'll remember the first step in all
of this was to say for a particular
opening guess maybe something like my
old favorite crane how likely is it that
you would see each of the possible
patterns and in this context where we
are shamelessly overfitting to the
wordle answer list all that involves is
counting how many of the possible
answers give each one of these patterns
and then of course most of our time was
spent on this kind of funny looking
formula to quantify the amount of
information that you would get from this
guess that basically involves going
through each one of those buckets and
saying how much information would you
gain that has this log expression that
is a fanciful way of saying how many
times would you cut your space of
possibilities in half if you observed a
given pattern
we take a weighted average of all of
those and it gives us a measure of how
much we expect to learn from this first
guess in a moment we'll go deeper than
this but if you simply search through
all 13 000 different words that you
could start with and you ask which one
has the highest expected information
it turns out the best possible answer is
sore which doesn't really look like a
real word
but i guess it's an obsolete term for a
baby hawk
the top 15 openers by this metric happen
to look like this but these are not
necessarily the best opening guesses
because they're only looking one step in
with the heuristic of expected
information to try to estimate what the
true score will be but there's few
enough patterns that we can do an
exhaustive search two steps in for
example let's say you opened with soar
and the pattern you happen to see was
the most likely one all grays
then you can run identical analysis from
that point for a given proposed second
guess something like kitty what's the
distribution across all patterns in that
restricted case where we're restricted
only to the words that would produce all
grays for soar and then we measure the
flatness of that distribution using this
expected information formula and we do
that for all 13 000 possible words that
we could use as a second guess
doing this we can find the optimal
second guess in that scenario and the
amount of information we were expected
to get from it
and if we wash rinse and repeat and do
this for all of the different possible
patterns that you might see we get a
full map of all the best possible second
guesses together with the expected
information of each
from there if you take a weighted
average of all those second step values
weighted according to how likely you are
to fall into that bucket it gives you a
measure of how much information you're
likely to gain from the guess soar after
the second step
when we use this two-step metric as our
new means of ranking the list gets
shaken up a bit sore is no longer first
place it falls back to 14th and instead
what rises to the top is slain
again doesn't feel very real
and it looks like it is a
british term for a spade that's used for
cutting turf
alright
but as you can see it is a really tight
race among all of these top contenders
for who gains the most information after
those two steps and even still these are
not necessarily the best opening guesses
because information is just the
heuristic it's not telling us the actual
score if you actually play the game
what i did is i ran the simulation of
playing all 2 315 possible wordle games
with all possible answers on the top 250
from this list
and by doing this seeing how they
actually perform the one that ends up
very marginally with the best possible
score turns out to be
saleh
which is
let's see sallae
an alternate spelling for sallae
which is a light medieval helmet
all right
if that feels a little bit too fake for
you which it does for me you'll be happy
to know that trace and crate give almost
identical performance and each of them
has the benefit of obviously being a
real word so there is one day when you
get it right on the first guess since
both are actual wordle answers
this move from sorting based on the best
two-step entropies to sorting based on
the lowest average score also shakes up
the list but not nearly as much for
example saleh was previously third place
before it bubbles to the top and crate
and trace were both fourth and fifth if
you're curious you can get slightly
better performance from here by doing a
little brute forcing there's a very nice
blog post by jonathan olsen if you're
curious about this where he also lets
you explore what the optimal following
guesses are for a few of the starting
words based on these optimal algorithms
stepping back from all this though i'm
told by some people that it quote ruins
the game to overanalyze it like this and
try to find an optimal opening guess you
know it feels kind of dirty if you use
that opening guess after learning it and
it feels inefficient if you don't but
the thing is i don't actually think this
is the best opener for a human playing
the game for one thing you would need to
know what the optimal second guess is
for each one of the patterns that you
see
and more importantly all of this is in a
setting where we are absurdly overfit to
the official wordle answer list the
moment that say the new york times
chooses to change what that list is
under the hood all of this would go out
the window
the way that we humans play the game is
just very different from what any of
these algorithms are doing we don't have
the word list memorized we're not doing
exhaustive searches we get intuition
from things like what are the vowels and
how are they placed i would actually be
most happy if those of you watching this
video promptly forgot what happens to be
the technically best opening guess and
instead came out remembering things like
how do you quantify information or the
fact that you should look out for when a
greedy algorithm falls short of the
globally best performance that you would
get from a deeper search
for my taste at least the joy of writing
algorithms to try to play games actually
has very little bearing on how i like to
play those games as a human the point of
writing algorithms for all this is not
to affect the way that we play the game
it's still just a fun word game it's to
hone in our muscles for writing
algorithms in more meaningful contexts
elsewhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you